you
if you were asked to make a list of the
most unpredictable secretive and
oppressive countries in the world today
it's a safe bet that North Korea would
probably be at the top as one of the
last remaining totalitarian regimes
North Korea and its line of
self-proclaimed supreme leaders have a
history of oppression human rights
violations and manipulation of its
citizens and the proclivity for displays
of military power in recent months we've
seen tensions rising between North Korea
and many member states of the United
Nations as Kim jong-un has aggressively
pursued his goal of making North Korea a
nuclear power with so many nations in a
military standoff now seems like a good
time to take a hard look at North Korea
is kim jeong-hoon a serious threat or is
he just the boy who cried Armageddon to
begin to understand North Korea's
current position in global affairs we
need to look back to 2003 Kim jong-un's
father Kim jong-il was supreme leader in
2003 and made the decision to withdraw
North Korea's membership in the Treaty
of the non-proliferation of nuclear
weapons after US allegations that North
Korea had started an enriched uranium
weapons program this made North Korea
the first nation to withdraw from the 3d
and needless to say caused concern among
the other signatories three years later
in 2006 North Korean officials announced
that they would conduct a nuclear test
in the future but did not provide a
specific date sure enough one week later
the United States Geological Survey
detected a magnitude four point three
seismic event emanating from within
North Korea which indicated a nuclear
test these suspicions were confirmed
shortly thereafter with an announcement
that the North had indeed completed a
successful underground test of a nuclear
fission device the consequences of this
test were severe the United Nations the
European Union and the individual
countries of the US Japan South Korea
and China enacted sanctions against
North Korea that targeted the country
systemic vulnerabilities by blocking
their offshore hard currency reserves
and reducing potential income with trade
and financial sanctions the overarching
goal of the long list of sanctions was
to diminish Kim's ability to pay for
North Korea's large military thereby
significantly weakening the nation
unfortunately for everybody these
sanctions have done little to curb Kim
Jong Un's enthusiasm for pursuing
nuclear proliferation in the years since
their first nuclear test North Korea has
conducted at least five more with
increasing power the most recent
detonated in September of 2016 is
considered to have been the largest
yield with estimations ranging
nine to twelve kilotons by comparison
the bomb that decimated Hiroshima in
World War two had a yield between 13 and
18 kilotons whereas the modern b83 bomb
the most powerful nuclear device in u.s.
active service has a yield up to 1.2
megatons
regardless of yield nuclear tests of any
sort are in direct defiance of United
Nations Security Council resolutions and
placed North Korea squarely on most of
the world's bad side in mid-april of
2017 North Korean officials announced
that they would be conducting another
nuclear weapon test very soon the North
claims to be improving their arsenal in
both quality and quantity and have
stated that their swords are drawn and
that the United States would be wise not
to provoke them further many have
suggested that the recent united states
air strike on Syria has caused North
Korea great concern as it appears that
the president has a low threshold for
use of force other nations around the
world are beginning to become uneasy
with the rising tension between the
United States and North Korea have two
of the most unpredictable people on the
world stage facing off against each
other
you have armed armadas in position and
you have 11,000 reportedly pieces of
artillery aimed at Seoul this explosive
situation question is how it will be
resolved but what would be the outcome
of open hostility between the two
nations the United States and its allies
in the region are certainly prepared for
the possibility and there are defenses
in place for the event of a nuclear
attack South Korea often consider to be
in the most immediate danger as what's
called the kill chain preemptive strike
system which is designed to alert the
military of North Korean missile launch
procedures and shut down the launch
facilities using South Korea's own
conventional warheads the u.s. and South
Korea engage in regular training to
prepare for such an eventuality and
practice what they refer to as the 4d
operational strategy which stands for
detect disrupt destroy and defend the
goal of this plan is to utilize
pre-emptive military options to
eliminate North Korean nuclear launch
capabilities and many suspect North
Korean leadership the idea of
pre-emptive strikes is difficult for a
number of reasons not the least of which
being the fact that such actions would
be hard to justify diplomatically but
another problem for pre-emptive strikes
is that as North Korean military power
increases more and more of their
missiles are being deployed on mobile
launchers scattered across the country
and the Army has started using
solid-fueled missiles which require far
less prep time
and can therefore be fired almost
entirely without warning making them
harder to track so what if the North
does manage to get their nuclear
missiles into the air South Korea and
Japan another likely target have missile
defense systems in place South Korea has
their K AMD system as well as the
support of an American bad battery which
was deployed following North Korea's
recent firing of 4 missiles into the Sea
of Japan between the two systems South
Korea has the ability to shoot down
North Korean missiles long before they
reach their intended target in addition
to land-based defenses the United States
South Korea and Japan have all deployed
several Aegis destroyers which have a
ballistic missile system capable of
tracking and eliminating multiple
missiles simultaneously the United
States has also placed its own missile
defense systems in Alaska and California
and Japan has plans to bolster its own
defenses while these defenses may seem
to make North Korean aggression a
non-issue that isn't exactly the case
there are some inherent problems with
missile defense systems namely most of
them have never been tested in actual
combat there is always the possibility
that one or several missiles could slip
through the defense's and cause
unspeakable damage there's also the
issue that North Korea may be able to
develop rockets capable of delivering
separating nuclear warheads making
defending from all of them nearly
impossible if it comes down to outright
war most experts agree that North Korea
would be overwhelmed by the strength of
the u.s. South Korea and other allies
but the death toll would likely be
horrendous in the event of all-out war
South Korea will execute what they call
the Korea massive punishment and
retaliation plan the objectives would be
to use Special Forces to [ __ ] North
Korean assets and eliminate their
leadership as well as completely
demolish Pyongyang using missiles and
artillery one unnamed South Korean
Defense official stated in an interview
the North's capital city will be reduced
to ashes and removed from the map every
pyongyang district particularly where
North Korean leadership is possibly
hidden will be completely destroyed by
ballistic missiles and high-explosive
shells
north Korea has repeatedly threatened
nuclear attacks on the United States but
it's suspected that it will take at
least a few years before they have the
capability the world knows North Korea
is working on intercontinental ballistic
missiles capable of striking the US but
it's uncertain just how far off they are
from reaching this goal then there's the
big question many have regarding this
tense situation why why would North
Korea put its very existence on the line
by pursuing their nuclear weapons
program and threat
world powers the best answer we have is
that North Korean officials truly
believe that securing their spot as a
nuclear power is the best way to ensure
their future safety with a massive
arsenal of weapons of mass destruction
who would dare challenge their glorious
leader Yong Yong fears that without
super weapons the United States which it
sees as the ultimate threat will
eventually wipe North Korea off the map
it's very difficult to understand the
reasoning behind the cult of personality
like Kim jong-un but it's put the world
in a very precarious spot some have
compared North Korea achieving nuclear
capabilities to a child finding his
father's handgun but in reality it's
more like a child showing up to a family
reunion with a box of homemade pipe
bombs in the detonator in hand it comes
down to a difficult decision launched a
preemptive strike and potentially save
tens of thousands of lives but start a
war in the process or attempt to deter
them and hope that they're bluffing
there's a fine line between deterrence
and provocation and we'll just have to
hope that the leaders involved know how
to walk that line if you'd like to learn
more about the history of North Korea
and its ambitions check out the links in
the description make sure to subscribe
if you haven't already and leave a
comment down below with what you think
about the rising tensions and potential
for war you can watch my other videos
about weapons and warfare by clicking
here or watch all of my videos by
clicking here make sure to follow second
thought on your favorite social media
and a special thank you to all my
patrons on patreon thanks for watching
and I'll see you in the next video